let's turn back the clock for a second
1996 a very very good year for you
yes it was it was the year that i got my
movie break in independence day
we have so much to talk about including
that in just a moment but 1996 was also
the year
michael jordan became a big screen star
in space jam well now
lebron james lebron james who lebron
james thank you for that
um he is taking over i'm a cartoon
what's up doc and i asked lebron's big
league co-star zendaya
about those photos kissing tom holland
what is it like to know that you broke
the internet people were so excited
because they're like
spider-man mj it's real well i'm excited
for the film to come out we're gonna
have a good press tour i think
and i'll probably see you on that too
yeah you will see me on that but i just
thought it was cool because people were
actually rooting
well thank you 24 year old zendaya
giving a master class on how to politely
dodge the question
but the picks don't lie last week she
and her spider-man co-star were snapped
smooching in la
seemingly confirming they are an item
off-screen the third installment is out
in december
but before that zendaya is the voice of
lola bunny in space jam a new legacy out
next friday
the tune squad doesn't give up i kind of
grew up with the film because both my
parents are
basketball players you gotta win this
game and get
our son back how was it acting alongside
lebron a guy who
excels in everything he does that's it
right there
he excels in everything he does right i
think he brought
that um championship mentality to the
set
let's end this who wins the one-on-one
in tune land between
lebron and spider-man i'm not gonna get
involved with that i think
spider-man is spider-man but lebron is
[Music]
lebron